Supplements I take
as someone who has suffered with their mental health
and has also come off antidepressants,
so I take these every single morning. Bit C,
magnesium by glycinate.
That's very important
because the bioavailability is better with by glycinate,
fish oils and Omega threes,
B6, vitamin B6,
vitamin B12.
And then I'd recommend vitamin D as well,
but I have really high vitamin D
because I got a blood test.
I get my bloods done quite regularly,
so I know exactly what I'm deficient in,
so I know what I need to take.
And then in my everyday smoothie,
I have creatine monohydrate,
I have glutamines,
really good for your gut.
I have niacin,
which is in this top one.
I have turmeric,
I have flaxseeds,
maca powder
and protein,
along with all the other goodness that I put in there.
All of those are just for me personally,
but they're really good baseline of supplements to take,
cause most people are deficient in things like
magnesium and B6 and things like that.
Magnesium is definitely a really good one.
And the glutamine,
creatine, obviously
for training,
um, VIXY is just great.
Anyway, um, so, yeah,
if you want any more details
or milligrams and that kind of thing,
just let me know.